great to be here in America I just moved
here I'm Canadian
nice yeah no but I just moved here a few
months ago
I looked at the current political
climate and I said now's the time right
I just learned an interesting law you
know up until recently it was illegal
for gay men to donate blood in America
which is not cool that discrimination
but they change the law recently where
gay men are now allowed to donate blood
which is great news there's just one
little caveat gay men can now donate
blood as long as they haven't had sex in
one year so that's even more ridiculous
that's crazy if you're not having sex
for one whole year that's a lifestyle
choice I can't get behind I have no
problem getting a blood transfusion from
a gay man but I'll be damned if I have
looser blood course and say my bad I'm
not getting myself I'm a straight man I
live with my girlfriend and she's a
sweetheart she's had to make a few
adjustments because I we're hearing it
and I'm sure you can see them right got
them here yeah I'm sure you can if you
can't see them get your eyes checked you
bunch of blind losers but no but I hate
all other disabilities and
the biggest adjustment my girlfriend's
had to make is I take my hearing aids
out when I go to sleep so you know when
we're lying in bed at the end of the day
there's no casual transition from
talking into sleeping when I take these
hearing aids out talking time is over
sleeping time has begun we even have a
little ritual we do now where before I
take them out I make like a last call
I'm like hey baby you got any final
thoughts on the day any closing remarks
because I'm about to shut this [ __ ] down
it's not all fun and games oh she said
something to me recently that shook me
you know rocked me to my very core she
said when we go to sleep at night when
you take out your hearing aids I feel
alone I feel very alone and I was like
whoa alone baby no you're not alone
remember that I'm right there beside you
and if anything happened in the middle
of the night anything at all I need you
to save me
[Applause]
you're not alone don't ever forget that
I need you so bad in fact I'm gonna need
you to start sleeping with your contacts
in please we're very vulnerable right
now
I take out my hearing aid you take out
your contacts you know as a unit we've
gone full Helen Keller I don't hear
whispering at all even with my hearing
aid Jen
whenever somebody whispers to me I'm
like if this is a secret you can rest
assured very very safe stays with us
mainly with you so worst I'm missing out
on all the good stuff right that you see
salacious details
nobody's ever whispering small talk
nobody's ever left it's a really
beautiful day out there why are you
whispering that no it's always the good
stuff and I'm missing out but I can hear
the first level of whispering you know
when somebody's kind of whispering but
there's still some volume I can hear
that but every level after that when I
get to lower and juicier I don't hear so
I just respond to the first part that I
heard and I end up a looking like a
[ __ ] you know like my friend came up to
me and she was like I was in Bermuda
last week
and I was like I have always wanted to
go to Bermuda
[Applause]
you